a dramatic new turn may be imminent in
the showdown between the Trump legal
team and special prosecutor Bob Muller
according to fox news sources Trump
attorneys are preparing to send the
special counsel a letter largely turning
down any questions related to
obstruction of justice during a
potential presidential interview but
Rudy Giuliani gave an interview just
posted on Politico where he leaves the
door open to some limited questioning
about obstruction which is an
interesting new development will this
spark though a major escalation between
both sides in the Russia probe joining
us now to analyze Alan Dershowitz author
of the big bestseller the case against
impeaching Trump insulting Berg former
deputy independent counsel in the
Whitewater investigation we'll also get
into the cantankerous TS LS the the
federal district judge who is presiding
over the Paul Manafort trial but let's
get to this this breaking news Rudy
Giuliani and this Politico interview you
probably haven't read it either of you
but he seems to leave open the
possibility of a very narrow set of
questions if it can be narrowed on
obstruction Alan I'll go to you first
what might be the wisdom in that well I
think Giuliani is tactic is to be able
to say to the public look our president
was willing to speak and Muller turned
him down
I think he's making Muller an offer that
Muller can't really accept he is putting
forth a kind of narrow window if Muller
accepts it then game on and we'll see
some narrow questioning but if I were
Trump's lawyer I'm not I would not under
any circumstances allow him to testify
because all you need is one question in
which he answers truthfully but somebody
else answers in a different way say he
says I didn't know about the meeting at
the Trump Tower involving the Russians
and Cohen says yes he did then you have
an opportunity to spring that perjury
trap so in the end
don't think lawyers generally will
advise a client to testify or sit down
with the prosecutor but I think this
client wants to be able to say I offered
to sit down and it was Muller who turned
me down so I think that's the strategy
okay here's some of the previous
conditions all placed on any potential
interview that Giuliani had set out and
we'll put it up on the screen for our
viewers could only be two to three hours
long narrow set of questions on
collusion they provide info on FBI
information first that they want that
information show proof that Trump
committed a crime show testimony is
needed to end the probe and curtail
obstruction questions so that's the one
that kind of was fleshed out a little
bit more tonight in Giuliani's comments
to Politico that last bullet point so
your reaction to these latest
developments do you agree with what
professor Dershowitz is positing there
well no prosecutor worth is salt is here
to accept those kind of preconditions
but there is a reason and I do agree
with and have long agreed with professor
Dershowitz his assertion that the
president shouldn't go in and answer
these questions is far too dangerous but
there's a reason Bob Muller has put up
with this dance for so long and I think
a lot of people don't understand it
if he issues a subpoena to force
President Trump to be interviewed by him
to go to the grand jury for example
certainly President Trump has to accept
that subpoena you can subpoena a
president but then when President Trump
invokes executive privilege
under the law the current law of the DC
Circuit in resealed case it is very
going to be very difficult and
time-consuming for Bob Mulder to ask the
questions he wants to ask particularly
about obstruction and there is
absolutely no guarantee that he will win
you're talking about the heart of
executive privilege here presidential
communications and presidential thought
processes and Muller would have to show
that it's very very important evidence
and that he can't get it anywhere else
and don't forget and
Jaworski when Jaworski won the tapes
case against Nixon and when Cox won the
earlier case they knew their subpoenas
were incredibly narrowly drawn they knew
the tapes existed they knew that were
particularly incriminatory conversations
on those tapes Muller does not have more
than more than anything else Muller does
not have the right to even litigate
executive privilege the first thing
president Trump is going to say is I'm
your boss you can't even be in court so
the reason why Muller has put up with
these ridiculous preconditions is that
he probably can't win if he goes to
court and in Allen they have already
gained this out you have Emmett flood
one of the top partners at Williams and
Connelly who's running this side of the
the legal prep inside the White House he
clerked for Justice Scalia he was my co
clerk on the second circuit for Ralph
winter brilliant guy they've already
gained this out correct I mean this is
really our enemy of course they had
gamed it out a long time ago remember
that was the firm that represented Bill
Clinton in his efforts to try to prevent
testimony in addition to his claim of
executive privilege there's also a
constitutional argument and that is that
since a senator and a congressman can't
be questioned about what they did on the
floor of the Senate
I don't believe a president can be
questioned about why he pardoned or why
he fired or why he tweeted or why he
exercised any of his powers under
article 2 of the Constitution or the
First Amendment so although I think in
the end if a subpoena was issued and
challenged
I think Muller would be able to get some
testimony from the president if he
stayed away from issues that are covered
by these privileges but in the end it
would be a Pyrrhic victory it would take
him so much time that it would guarantee
that the report could not be written
until after the midterm elections Wow we
don't have time to get to TS Ellis and
how well he was a little cantankerous
but we're gonna when we have you back
well I mean this is gonna be going on
for at least another week or so but he's
a tough judge he's a tough judge you got
a look
me when I talk to you that's what I say
to my kids tell us the truth looking at
you yeah you know he does this with
everybody he does this with everybody
but it but it doesn't make it right he
needs to he needs to really hold back
and let the litigators try their case
but he did the right thing when he
talked about mana for and why they're
going after him he told the truth about
that a truth that too few people are
willing to recognize I think he want to
live it doesn't need to be doing that in
front of the jury though what he's
saying you have tears in your eyes
no and that Greg is not in front of the
jury yeah oh no I don't I'm sorry but it
is very dramatic but it might be a
little too much all right guys thanks so
much